uh the minutes of the last
meeting Pages five five to
nine are we to approve as a correct
record move
chair happy with those thank you item
four the medium-term financial plan 10
to 31 that's over to
you today I'm presenting the medium term
and financial plan for the current
Year's budget along with the original
budget for
2425 and the plan and planning budgets
for the following three years 27 to
28 there are no M major changes in the
current budget we are still in on track
to identify the remaining Savings of
331,000 and will report progress in the
quarter three monitoring next month
we'll start with the general fund for
the 2425 budget the main points to note
are the draft Financial settlement was
released on the 18th of
December was for two years of it was
year two of a two-year
settlement new homes bonus was paid
again for a final year and the 3%
funding guarantee was also included
again table one shows the grants of
awarded totaling
990,000 the funding reforms have again
been delayed and will not be considered
now until after the general election so
it is widely expected that 2526 will be
a further rollover budget and our
forecasts reflect
this table two shows a forecast position
for the next four years
2025 the gap before any council tax
increase is
302,000 the resilience Reserve will be
utiliz will will be
used utilized to fund this budget but we
are confident that this s these savings
will be achieved uh during the
year the council tax increase of
2.99% is is recommended for 20
2425 table two demonstrates how
important the council tax access to us
providing 40% of the annual income to
the general fund it is also very
important to note that the annual
increases not only Services the current
Year's budget but also increases the
base for future
years our commitment to robust F
Financial Management is helping us
maintain this strong position with the
budgets cash limited wherever possible
the main growth item each year is pay
2.3 million has been added for 23 24 and
2425 there is a lot of uncertainty from
26 to 27 but assuming funding reforms
take place then budget pressures begin
to mount as a result as a result changes
to the funding methodology loss of
government grants and the business rate
reset will all have significant Dre
mental impacts on us the DLC have
committed to transitional relief
payments for the first two years of
reforms and we have included this in our
estimates whilst they don't mitigate the
loss entirely they provide time for us
to
adjust 51 uh 151 officer has provided a
view on the adequacy of our reserves in
the Mt FP and has no concerns at this
time the resilience Reserve will
continue to provide protection against
the budget
gaps the its Reserve remains at the
healthy level and the general fund
balance remains intact at 2 million or
11% of national net
budget onto the HRA the main points of
note is the pressure being created by
increased demand and the impact impact
of
Regulation offices at the council and
Ral homes are working closely together
to continue to provide high quality
housing service for our tenants but also
meet expectations for the housing social
housing
regulator but the associated costs of
delivery are
growing the additional cost cost known
to us at this time have been included in
the budget and reel's management fee and
the position will be kept under
review having taken into consideration
the budget pressures the impact on
tenants and the rent standards which
allows rent increases up to
7.7% the annual rent increase we are
recommending to council this year is
6% finally onto the capital Pro program
main points are to note that the
majority of the Town deal projects will
be completed in
2425 which after which the general fund
Capital program reduces
considerably as well as the 57 million
investment in our stock over the next
four years the HRA Capital program also
includes new build schemes at North
Wingfield on the Regeneration St scheme
at Stone Brom so in summary we recognize
that we are in a better financial
position than many local authorities
some of whom are struggling to set a
balanced budget next year but
nonetheless we do appre
appreciate it that with still time still
need to continue to tackle the
underlying forecast budget deficit in a
planned and managed manner I'm happy to
take any questions and move
recommendations in 1 to4 in the report
chair any
questions any comment no just a quick
one there was announcement Yesterday by
government about giving more is how is
that going to affect us I'll defer that
one to Jane but not
much so so the government did announce
um rather late that there were going to
be some changes to the funding
settlement it won't be confirmed until
early February what that will actually
look like for individual authorities but
um we've done some calculations based on
what we expect it to be most of it's
going to social care so most of it's
going to the upper tiers um rightly so I
think that's what the real presses are
um there's some additional rural
Services Grant which is rural districts
which we don't apply for the one that
affects us is they're moving the 3%
funding guarantee which is a one-off
grant that they bought in last year as
part of the current settlement package
um they're adjusting that from 3% to
4% that's going to make us £92,000
so it does have the in it does have the
benefit of if this budget's approved at
Council on Monday the 2425 shortfalls
300,000 the council tax that brings it
down to 100,000 with the 92 from the
funding secondment where pretty much
it's a balance budget for
2425 thank you I must admit I heard that
on the way in we weren't going to get
much it was mainly the county count fors
uh I thought when I was told the figure
that we're expecting I thought well we
balance the budget this year correct I
think I've been on a a zoom call this
morning we all leaders nationally uh and
and like you say it does help the the
social services stuff uh but I think
bottom line is it's a oneoff it's not
going into B budget so next
year they'll take that away again uh and
it'll probably come in after everybody
set the budgets anyway won't it so it's
it's just a winfall basically for this
year uh and basically it don't it don't
tell many district
really that sums it up perfectly it is
just a windfall it's a one off we've not
even got any guarantees that the 3%
funding guarantee will be it will
because we're assuming next year as a
roll over thank you y there are some
caveats in it as well AR J they oh yeah
they affect us they yeah I don't think
they'll affect us financially but
there's a nice little paragraph at the
end of the um the Press announcement and
I know no more than you do because we've
not received anything at all from DLo
yet we've literally just seen The
Minister's announcement talking about
wanting information about efficiencies
and reserves again so
so we'll be providing that information
when you request it later the
year so so mainly today it's that we
agree this to go to full Council on
munding that what we can I can I just
make one point for the the M morning say
I do apologize for this but at 1.29 the
UN contribution for 2425 budget that
figure is actually incorrect Council kry
read the right figure out which is
303,000 so the call on reserves is
significantly less than mentioned at
1.29
I have corrected that in the report
that's gone to council just wanted to
make you a of that tonight so my
apologies it doesn't affect any of the
overall numbers it just changes that in
the full report it 1.29
correct stay away for
it at
1.29 the third line just says the planed
contribution to 2425 budget of 970,000
.79 million that should be 303,000 which
is the figure
that
600,000 it's last year's
fig want a good new story last year
improved
3,000 I shouldn't got it wrong in the
report in the first place I
just I know
mentioned all so the recommendations and
I've lost it now you've recommendations
in one to 14
got
you so we're are we all in favor of
those recommendations that are in the
report to go to council yeah
yes chair thank you yeah when it's full
Council they'll have to go in two
sections 1 to8 will go first and then we
have to do the housing revenue account
because uh we have some people that are
tied up with r have to leave at at that
time uh so you know we take the 9 to 14
uh while we're
out yeah thank you chair yeah just just
to remind you at that point you will
have to elect to chair as well yeah yeah
of course the chair and vice chair will
both
leave
we not thought that
through and
anybody with outstanding debt on the
rent account that living a rented
property could declare an interest I
don't know now I you we used to have to
go through it because it was about two
counsel regularly but that's a long time
ago three you chair we we have that
information ready for the meeting we
need it but there we need it I don't I
don't think it probably occurs now but
for a long time we had to couple it okay
thank you uh the publication of the
first biodiversity net gain report I'm
looking forward to this
one when you said looking forward to I
thought you were going to come with some
no no I I love biodiversity I'm glad you
do because it's part our Greener bit The
Cleaner Greener safer um and it's
something that we've all been committed
to not only that it is a statutory
requirement David will tell us more
about it in a minute and as part of that
statutory requirement we have to um
produce
statements um on what we're planning to
do what we're going to do and what our
current position is um obviously I'd
seen this before it needs to be done
publicly um I've agreed this earlier on
in the month so do you want to give a
bit more information on that David yeah
have to thanks counc yes so um the the
reason for this report basically set out
in the 2021 environment act which
basically expanded on a previous Duty
around biodiversity um and in the 2021
act there was a specific responsibility
on public bodies so this council is one
of those um to conserve and enhance biod
diversity and to demonstrate how we're
doing that so the purpose of the report
is essentially to do that to cover the
activity that we've undertaken in this
the last year and then set out a a set
of
actions um which we've our first
consideration so effectively the the
seven actions that are in the report in
part two um are essentially summarize
the activity we've undertaken in the
last calendar year we've been working
with um darish Wildlife Trust on those
and we do currently have a service level
agreement with the wildlife trust to
provide us with at the moment prod
dominant uh comments on planning
applications where there's biodiversity
net gain assessments this whole area of
net gain is expanding in terms of the um
the requirements on developers because
as of the 12th of M February it's now
been agreed that the um there will be a
legal requirement from De developers to
produce a 10% net gain on major
development sites so that sites of 10
dwellings or more or th square meters or
more if it's clearly not residential um
so in those cases developers have a
specific Duty um and the wildlife trust
are in place to help us deal with that
there would be a procurement exercise to
go through um in terms of the seven
actions because that's obviously a much
more detailed report and it relates to
work that we as a council are doing not
not developers so it is a a separate
element um but we will be going through
that procur exercise and I think is to
come back to Cabinet in terms of a kind
of the detailed action plan um so part
two sets out thetion three of the report
is a
broad um action plan and kind of
attributes uh a year over one to five
fiveyear plan um and clearly each
element will require quite a lot of work
and meet on the bones so happy to come
back to cabinet in the future uh
regarding those but essentially the the
um recommendation is to um approve the
publication of this report on the
council's website it is a require
but obviously it's something brought
here because it's it requires kind of
organizational buying and I think an
awful lot of positive work goes on in
this regard and there's a lot of there's
a lot more work to do um it fits in with
um you know a review of our Council
assets and various things that we uh
measures that we will need to be
undertaken as part of local plan review
so this will run through an awful lot of
work that we're doing um so at the
moment it's publication of this report
but it's nice and come back no doubt
thank you chair thank you D we we sort
to alluded to a bit yesterday didn't we
in the strategy for looking at somewh
our land but I've just looking at this
wild planting policy which I
didn't uh sort to tweak till till uh
just WR but that's something we can
definitely look at is it David like that
we've got lots of land where we can
develop us rather than just ping
buildings yes CH I think you're
absolutely right with that and uh I mean
since uh last May it's a conversation
I've been having with Street Scene
looking at where we develop um while
flower planting you know and have a um a
mixture of some of our traditional Beds
which which serve the district quite
well it makes us look a nice place and
have wild planting in that and as David
said we've got pieces of land ultimately
potentially that aren't being used for
anything that we could develop and when
this is public hopefully might interest
some of our residents as well who want
to make comments or be involved in
suggestions about that I mean I think
that' be quite a nice thing to do it's a
good opportunity to really look at how
we do make the district greener in as
well as bringing buers and developers on
site as well and encouraging them to
take that biodiversity agenda yeah um
I'm happy to move the recommendation
chair with that thank you I'll second
that are we all in favor yeah
thank you Dave that's
great uh item six delegating authority
to officers to enter into planning
performance agreement with
development you want that one Steve this
me this me again yes it's I mean
planning performance Agreements are a
tool that are used but it encourages um
uh developers to have contacts with us
you know to start that process off
rather than do things cold it can save
money in the long run um and perhaps
David wants to elaborate on that if you
would please yeah that's fine cast thank
you um so um there are powers delegated
to to officers to introduce um new
charges effectively to services but I
think given the um potential uh take up
of these which might be quite um
significant on our larger scale projects
once we introduce it and also the of
public interest element we thought is
best to come to Cabinet to have this
discussion the the purpose of planning
performance agreement is effectively um
to give developers certainty in terms of
the time scale for delivery of a project
um and as um Council pick said it turn
to start with pre-application advice
engagement but would also cover the
processing of running application with
the sole purpose of recovering the cost
to the authority of deal application so
this is not a an income generating
measure it's a cost recovery measure and
that's needs to be very clear um and
there's an appendix one to the report is
a draft guidance note which I produced
um which would go on the website if we
make a decision to um endorse um plan
performance agreements is perhaps a bit
of a strong word I mean in the end it's
it's a voluntary Arrangement where we've
had um couple of developers Express an
interest in per in in going down this
rout um and there's one um draft
agreement in place at the moment which
we will pursue should should cabinet
make the decision to to Endor this
General approach today um but the the
guidance note effectively explain what
plan performance Agreements are um talks
about those things that they're not you
know this is no way a guarantee of the
outcome for a planning application um
and it is not an exercise in gaining
money over costs to
um the the cost exercise which has to be
gone through is is rigorous it would be
based on an officer hourly rate and the
scope of each plan performance agreement
will inevitably be different because
they're specific to a prodject but it
would only be case agree developer how
much time officers will be involved in
the project and then a clear link to
actually charge it so there would be a
clear audit Trail um and the the
guidance also goes into effectively how
we would administer them as a plan
Department in terms of what can
reasonably expect um as part of that
process um so nothing else to add at
this point chair but any questions are
there any questions D or no no chairman
the come I think David's um you some the
only con the worry that we initially had
was that it might be might be seen in
correctly as um having some favoritism
or having some influence on on an
outcome of a decision it clearly doesn't
do that it doesn't no way negate um the
planning committee or anything else
that's taking place and the public
statement I think makes that in David's
that is put on the website makes that
quite clear yeah that that is not the
case so um I think it's I think it's a
benefit to us I'm quite happy to move
the
recommendation chair point one that's
good I'll second that are we all in
favor the recommendations well one
two thank
you uh agent items I've not had any
agent
item anybody no exclusion of the public
there the leader to move and I start
reading this
out the public being excluded from the
meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business to avoid
disclosure to them of exempt information
has the defined in part one of schedule
12a to the Local Government Act
1972 as amended by the local government
St access to information variation order
2006 the category of information dat
after each
item that
all members
content
really thank you right Martin can you
confirm the streams hand
just a
recording hello Mar can you hear
you I think we just work on the
Assumption it has ended
chair we assumed thank you item nine
then purches of 15 units for affordable
rent ATS to a yeah go have a
look press M camera off thank
you